[Music]
good afternoon everyone
welcome to Google cloud next 2017 my
name is Dominic Crossan and here with
Robert Cuba's from our developer
advocate team and we're going to spend
some time talking about cloud spanner so
what are the goals of this session first
of all we want to take you through a
brief history of spanner and why spanner
exists then we're going to give you an
explanation of what spanner is today and
what is available to you in the public
beta and then any good session has a
demo and Robert will be taking you
through a demo the goal is to talk for
about 30 minutes do a 10 minute demo and
then hopefully have 20 minutes for
people to ask questions at the end so
hold your questions at the end and then
please come up to the mic and ask your
question so we can make sure that we get
your question on the recording so why
the spanner exists let's go back to 2005
every dollar that Google generated from
its advertising system AdWords was on
the back of a manually sharded my sequel
database that database was charted
according to customer IDs and occasion
we'd have to recharge the database we
did a recharge I and that Rashard
actually took multiple years to complete
it was at that point we decided that
there's probably a better way so we
started development of spanner so as we
were looking at the requirements for the
AdWords system what were the things that
Google needed Google needed a
horizontally scalable daily database we
had lots of customers we were going
quickly
you know we had gone from a 10 million
dollar a year business to over a billion
dollar a year business and we needed to
support that scale so we needed the
horizontal scalability the second thing
is we were dealing with people's money
we had budgets we had customers we had
partners we had agencies we had to have
asset transactions with global
consistency we couldn't accept [ __ ]
ventually or any loss of data so we had
to make sure that it was always
consistent and we always had asset
transactions the third thing was every
minute that the AdWords system was down
for maintenance was millions of dollars
revenue from for Google and so we had to
have a system that made sure that we
didn't have any downtime so these are
the requirements and if you look at this
today prior to cloud spanner entering
the market there was no good solution
that met all of these requirements that
brings us to cloud spanner we demand a
lot of our databases in our databases
demand a lot of us they're fragile
expenses and tough to maintain when
things break it can be hard to put the
pieces back together at the speed of
your business
and you often lose data in the process
we've all come to expect the distributed
databases can't be globally consistent
and scalable but what if you didn't have
to make trade-offs what if you could
have a fully managed database service
that's consistent scales horizontally
across data centers and seek sequel this
is clouds banners a mission-critical
relational database service built from
the ground up and battle-tested at
Google for strong consistency and high
availability at global scale at Google
we use scanner for services that
billions of people access every day it's
the only cloud service designed to be a
massively distributed relational
database with transaction and sequel
semantics and we're talking massive
spanner can scale up to millions of
machines across hundreds of data centers
and trillions of database road stretches
across the globe while behaving with it
all in one place where you want it we've
built cloud spanner to be fully managed
insecure automatic sharding and
synchronous replication with low latency
and schema updates without downtime
means your data is highly available and
reliable instead of endless provisioning
and worrying about maintenance you can
focus on growing your business no matter
your needs you don't have to hit a wall
with your database service get started
with cloud spanner and build what's next
[Music]
right so that is our quick introduction
into what is cloud spanner
so cloud spanner is Google's
mission-critical scalable relational
database service so almost ten years
after the internal standard project went
into production side Google we've been
able to bring that same level of
performance and consistency and
scalability to our Google cloud platform
customers so what does that really mean
so first of all cloud spanner is a fully
managed database service so what that
means is you don't have to worry about
upgrades you don't have to worry about
security patches you don't have to worry
about adding storage to your storage
array for the next set of data that's
going to come at your database system
all that is handled for you by our site
reliability engineering team who is
making sure 24 by 7 that that service is
up and running and that we're meeting
your needs now we get fairly fanatic
inside of Google around consistency and
so when we say acid transactions and
we've seen global consistency we mean
externalize external realisability so
it's the highest standard of consistency
there's a lot of back-and-forth in the
industry about what is eventual
consistency or what is global
consistency and we take a very high bar
on this and spanner meets that need so
this means that you have acid
transactions across many rows you have
relational semantics so if you're coming
off of a manually shard in my sequel
database or a Postgres cluster or some
other sequel solution everything looks
familiar so your schemas are defined in
DDL so standard sequel with sequel
datatypes you are able to do queries
based on your joins and everything
you're used to having in sequel in fact
cloud spanner uses the same sequel
dialect as what we've rolled out in
bigquery which is based on ANSI sequel
2011 with some extensions for the
additional features that Google offers
so we did standard sequel and it's the
same sequel that you get across the
Google cloud platform on our data
warehousing product bigquery
it's automatic synchronous replication
so today in the beta we've rolled out
regional versions of cloud spanner so
what that means is we have multiple
replicas across multiple zones inside of
a single region and this gives you four
nines of availability it also means that
when you write data into spanner in the
cloud spanner you know that it has been
written if we've given you an
acknowledgement that that transaction
has committed then you know that that
data is there and any reads that you do
after that
time stamp will include that data we
give these guarantees and so that you
always know that you're getting the most
consistent view of your data at all
times or a consistent view retained at
all times
later in the year we'll be rolling out
multi-regional so multi-regional means
that you can actually span your database
across multiple Google cloud platform
regions to achieve an even higher level
of availability so multi regional cloud
spanner instances will offer five nines
of availability so what that means is
you're talking about twenty seconds a
month I'm sorry two seconds two months
of downtime with five nines and this has
been battle tested and the reason that I
can get up to on stage and make these
types of claims is because we know that
we've done this internally so we've been
doing this at Google for almost ten
years with the internal spanner system
and so we know that when we make these
guarantees of availability and
consistency and durability we can stand
behind them because we have almost ten
years of battle-tested experience
running it internally Google Cloud
spanner has been used internally for
many of our mission-critical
applications so we've talked about
Google Adwords the Google Playstore and
in fact Google cloud platform itself is
built on top of cloud spanner so the
control plane that manages all of the
VMS and all of the services across
Google cloud platform is actually based
on spanner so you can have confidence
that when you put your data and build
your application on the top of cloud
spanner you're getting the best of what
Google has to offer so down next you
just set a bunch of words what does that
mean how does that compare to other
solutions so if you compare it to a
traditional relational database for
traditional art of VMs
we have strong schemas we have sequel
schemas and querying we have strong
consistency we have high availability
quite often I get asked how does Cloud
spanner compare to the our DBMS that I'm
using either on-premise or in another
public cloud and invariably they're
trying to compare a single node solution
to spanner which is a distributed system
so when you have a single node master
slave configuration you're dependent on
the master node that means that you can
only do as many rights as you can put
through the master node and if the
master node needs to be updated either
get a new version of software get a
security patch we need to do any
maintenance you either have to take the
master node down and take down the whole
system or failover your master node to
your slave so you can do maintenance on
the master what this means is that your
application will will incur downtime now
that downtime might be scheduled but
it's still downtime for Google it
doesn't matter
we're selling ads around the world we
can't schedule downtime we're making
money and we have a system that is
reliant on the system 24/7 so we can't
have downtime either scheduled or
unscheduled so Cloud spanner because of
its distributed nature means that we can
do updates security updates any
maintenance that we need to do in the
system by moving your data around on the
multiple nodes and you don't see any
downtime in fact you see nothing on the
performance side of what you experience
you'll see a consistent experience even
when we're doing things like upgrades
and security patches so in that sense
it's horizontally scalable so the way
that you achieve additional scale is you
add nodes which is what you would
normally see in a no sequel database
which we'll talk about a second so
instead of relying on vertical
scalability which means that if I need
more throughput through my master slave
I just put it on a bigger box I give it
more RAM I give it more memory and so
that's a vertical scaling strategy and
so with spanner we give you horizontal
scalability so you don't worry about you
know I'm on the biggest VM I really hope
this provider makes a bigger VM because
I'm going to run
soon right you know that we can always
add additional capacity so you can grow
your application also replication
so traditional art of EMS is one of the
ways you can scale out horizontally as
you can shard your read and write for
clothes so you can add additional read
replicas to your system and then you can
do your reads off of those read replicas
therefore giving additional write
capacity to your master node now the
problem there is that those reads of the
read replicas are sale there is a
replication lag for the data that's
making that read replicas and so it's up
to you and your application to know that
you may or may not have the most
consistent version of the data if you
need a consistent read you have to go
back to the master node and therefore
using up some of those resources and
take away from your scalability so
that's how it relates to a traditional
art idea mask how does it relate to node
sequel so the pattern that we would see
over and over and over again with our
customers is both our enterprise and our
are startups and smaller companies is
that they would build an application
using a traditional art via mass IV my
sequel might be post Chris might be
named your commercial database and then
what happens is they just through and we
all know that data is growing
exponentially it is growing faster at a
faster rate than it's ever grown in our
history and so there were the
requirements that we have in our
databases continues to grow and so often
what happens is a company or project has
this relational database that back their
application and they hit the upper bound
of what they can do for scale so they're
only immutable requirement is horizontal
scalability so they then go and choose a
no sequel solution
Cassandra MongoDB whatever happens to be
and they basically trade global
consistency for [ __ ] it's got a
horizontal scalability because that is
their immutable requirement and then
they write a bunch of application logic
or use other tools to try to get around
the transactional semantics of having
consistently only at a shard level or
not across the entire database
so what spanner allows you to do is to
not have to make this trade-off
now if you've outgrown your R to be a
mess cloud spanner is not a drop-in
replacement it's not a my sequel
palatable database it's not a post kiss
compatible database so there is going to
be work for you required to migrate your
traditional rTMS applications on the
cloud spanner but you get to know that
when you make that transition you don't
have to make a trade-off between
horizontal scalability and global
consistency I'm often asked what was the
hardest thing about taking the internal
standard application and exposing it to
our Google cloud platform customers and
the answer is making it open so Google
is committed to being the open cloud and
so we've done everything we can to adopt
open standards and existing protocols
and api's that exists in the outside
world we aren't trying to move everyone
on the google proprietary technology
we're trying to move and solve customers
needs where they are by supporting those
standards and so cloud spanners spent a
tremendous amount of time trying to make
sure that this was true so we started
with standard sequel we've had a number
of different sequel dialects across the
Google cloud platform and so we decided
that we needed to come to a standard
sequel dialect across all Google
products so we took an C sequel 2011 as
a spec and then extended that and so
what this means is when you look at
sequel spanner sequel in spanner you see
normal sequel data types and the types
of queries and joins and things that you
would expect so we make it as easy as
possible for customers by reducing the
friction and the impedance and impedance
mismatch between their existing
solutions the second thing is we spend a
lot of time on enterprise requirements
cloud spanner actually launched with the
best integration across all of our
various cross-platform initiatives for
Identity and Access Management
encryption and audit logging it came out
of the gates in button beta with all of
the features that a traditional
enterprise that has high security needs
would need to be able to adopt this
product and so we spent a lot of time
investing in that and making sure that
the product had those features from the
very beginning we also spent a lot of
time in client libraries so we'd like to
talk about being a very developer
friendly platform and being developer
friendly means two things it means
you've got great document
and great documentation and you have
really strong client libraries so we
spent a ton of time working with our
early access customers cloud spanner was
in early access for over 12 months and
what we were doing in that time was
onboarding customers showing the
documents finding the holes in the
places that we forgot to document things
adding those documents and really doing
lots of iterations on the documentation
so that when we launched we actually had
all of that ready for our developers the
second thing that was really important
was our client libraries we spent a ton
of time on our Java Python go and nodejs
client libraries to make sure that they
were fully baked
they were optimized for performance we
obscured any of the common gotchas that
you would have if you were trying to use
the API directly in an idiomatic way for
the language so we spent a ton of time
working with the various teams to make
sure that we had a first-class developer
client library in these languages the
last thing is JDBC so in case you
haven't heard this yet at the partner
ecosystem is incredibly important to
Google and so one of the things that we
did to make it as easy as possible for
both customers to adopt and partners is
that we launched with a JDBC driver that
JDBC driver is read-only and what that
means is that we can hand that to a
number of our partners or your internal
customers and they have a fully
understood client library that they can
often plug in with very little work to
their frameworks and this allowed us to
launch integrations with a number of
partners early because we were able to
deliver them a JDBC driver and that was
able to decrease the time necessary for
them to implement access in the cloud
spanner
so what types of workloads are
appropriate for cloud spanner so as we
were going through the early access
program we saw a number of patterns
emerge from the types of use cases that
people found for cloud spanner so the
first one was transactional if you have
an application that requires
transactional consistency or complex
transactions then that is an ideal use
case for spanner so if you're dealing
with things like inventory management
where you can't sell more products than
you have or if you are trying to manage
financial transactions you have to make
sure that you always have the right
amounts and you have to have really
strong transactional semantics to be
able to support that so what we saw is a
number of the companies that we've
worked with had a manually charted
system or has built a transactional
system on top of their manually sharded
or eventually consistent data store to
make sure that they were getting
guaranteeing transactional consistency
so what spanner allows you to do is to
push all of the transactional code and
all of the responsibilities for
maintaining transactional consistency
into the database so what this means is
that you have much simpler architectures
much higher velocity for your developers
less code that can go wrong and
introduce bugs because you can rely on
the database itself for maintaining and
providing all of your transactional
consistency the second one was scale out
and people often assume that unless they
have tons of data they can't use spanner
and the answer is if you have a
mission-critical system that requires
high availability then spanner can be a
great fit for you if you have 10
gigabits then 10 gigabytes of data or
you have a petabyte of data it doesn't
matter you have a mission critical
application and so cloud spanner gives
you a cloud native mission-critical
database that also provides scale so if
you have hit the upper bounds of what
you can do and we continue to see other
cloud providers and database providers
rolling out kind of incremental changes
in the amount of data that they can
store what spanner does is allows you to
have a non incremental change we go from
being able to store you know specific
single-digit terabytes of data into as
much data as you have so if you happen
to have a very large customer set or
large number of transactions are a lot
of data that you have to have
transactional consistency the spanner
allows you to meet that need without
having to take any trade-offs another
common use case is global data plane and
this is very common inside of Google and
actually the Google cloud platform use
case so if you have let's say that you
have user bases that are around the
world you have a set of users in North
America a set of users in Europe and a
set of users of Asia and you want to
keep all the user data close to the
customers then you can do that you could
have a regional instance or an AR DBMS
in the US one in Europe and one in Asia
but what you need to know is have a
single global system that tells you
where that data lives so for this user
user ABC I know that that data that user
is home in Europe so I'm going to go to
the European instance to go ahead and
get that data and so this global control
plane where it might be a very small
amount of data but you have to be able
to query it from everywhere have low
latency and know that you have a
consistent view of the data is another
very common use case we saw both inside
of Google and we're starting to see more
commonly in the outside world
the last one is database consolidation
so everyone knows the story right you
keep your user data in my sequel or
Postgres you keep all your event and
logs data in a Cassandra cluster or in
bigquery and then you ETL the data
around right every night you copy a copy
of your user table into bigquery so you
can do joins against it what we've seen
with cloud spanner is it allows you to
consolidate your databases into a single
source of truth so you could take your
user data to sit might be in Postgres or
in my sequel and you can merge it with
all the events data that you have in
Cassandra or MongoDB or bigquery and you
can combine them into a single database
you no longer have the ETL data around
you don't have to worry about staleness
of data you can do joins across all the
data and you know that you have a single
consistent source of truth for all of
your data again it is a tremendous gain
and productivity for your development
teams if they don't have to worry about
multiple data stores if you can put all
of your data in one place in cloud
spanner makes sense for that it removes
tremendous complexity from your stack so
that removes bugs it makes it easier to
maintain code
food increases developer velocity on and
this is again something we've seen a lot
inside of Google and we're starting to
see with our Google cloud platform
customers so how does Spanish do this I
say that it's horizontally scalable so
what does that mean
so for cloud spanner you start with the
cloud spanner instance and Robert is
going to demo how to actually create one
of these and you can see how easy it is
but you create a cloud spanner instance
and when you create that instance you
basically tell us what you want your
replication topology to look like so if
you're using a regional spanner instance
we have multiple replicas in multiple
zones inside of a single region and then
each of those replicas has its own set
of compute resources and storage and
then you put your database inside of
that instance so an instance can have
100 databases and then each database can
have 2,000 tables in each of those
tables can have as many rows as you want
and so what this means is that your data
is actually replicated across each of
the replicas and we've got full copies
of all the data in all the places and so
there is multiple replicas running at
any given time so what happens is if
somebody comes in and wants to make an
update so let's say that you want to
update a row in a database or let's say
you want to update 100 rows that update
comes into the system and goes into one
of the replicas this is where spanner
magic starts to happen that that update
comes into the system we know that each
of the different replicas has parts that
we they have all the data but we know
that certain parts of the data are owned
by different nodes so when that update
comes in we come in and we notify the
appropriate nodes and then that data
gets replicated across all of the
replicas we use a custom
paxos algorithm that allows us to do
consensus based writes on the system and
this is what allows us to have our
global consistency so we have a custom
taxes algorithm and we have two-phase
commits which allows us to have global
consistency across the database at all
times we try to do everything without
the two-phase commit but if you actually
are joining if you're trying to update
data across multiple nodes then we fall
back to a two-phase commit to make sure
that we don't lose consistency of the
database
so this is all well and good and spanner
sounds magic but there has to be some
differences they're happy they can't
just be a drop-in replacement and the
answer is you're right so to get the
advantages of a distributed system we
impose certain design constraints that
we impose certain concepts so the first
one is the way that we lay out the data
so in a regular relational database if
you had two sets of data that were
related you would have two tables and
you may or may not have a foreign key
constraint which would allow you know if
you delete one row then it deletes all
of those two children rows and so this
is the way you would lay it out in
normal relational database Postgres
sequel does support Chekov child tables
which implements some of this but for
different reasons so what we've done in
spanner to make it performant and to
help customers tell us what data should
be grouped together we have the concept
of in early tables so what this means is
that when you have tables that are
dependent on each other
you literally interleave them together
into the same table so you can see our
top-level row is the Beatles where the
artist ID is number one and then we have
albums that are under it that have that
are from the artist and they have IDs 2
1 & 2 so we have primary key for Beatles
which is 1 and then 1 & 2 which is the
primary key is for the child table what
this tells us is that all of the
information but as under Beatles is
related it's so what that allows us to
do is to group all of the data together
on a single node so if you commonly are
doing queries where you say show me all
of the songs for the Beatles or show me
all the albums for the Beatles and you
know that your queries are going to be
within a subset of the data by using in
early tables you can tell us the logical
grouping of your data and this allows us
to do a better job of splitting the data
across multiple nodes which allows us to
respond to queries more quickly because
we don't have to rely on two-phase
commit we can serve all the data off of
that one section of the data in a very
quick way
so what does this look like from a
schema point of view so when you define
your schema as we talked about we used
EDL's standard sequel create table
singers singer ID int is in 64 not no
singer name is a string max length and
primary key is singer ID so we need this
primary key to know how to split your
data up in charter data across nodes so
then if albums is a subset of all this
data and it's dependent on the parent
table then we can say create table
albums singer ID in 64 so child tables
have to have all of the primary keys of
its parent so it has to have singer ID
and then we've added album ID as a
second primary key and we also have an
album bein which is string and then when
we define the table we say inner
leave-in singers and so this is the
concept of foreign key constraints that
spanner supports it's not arbitrary
foreign key constraints because that
doesn't work on a distributed system by
telling us how to group all the data
together then you can start to do things
like cascade on delete and some of the
other benefits that you get from a
foreign key constraint but we only do
this at a in early table basis the other
thing that's great that I love telling
customers about is schema migration so
the other thing that it allows us to do
is no downtime schema migrations so you
can actually alter your table and add a
column in this case age we can apply
that to the database and that updates
the schema on the fly so no downtime
online and you know that once that
transaction the schema update is out of
the transaction once that commits you
know that all subsequent reads after
that transaction have the new data again
getting back to the problem we talked
about with AdWords we couldn't handle
either locking the database or shutting
down the database to do schema
migrations we needed to be able to do
schema migrations on the fly so
alterations to the schema are our online
so what does this look like encode so in
any of these sessions we try to give you
actionable information I'm a Python guy
so I've gone ahead and told the Python
code so if you use our Google cloud
client libraries so we have we've rolled
open source client libraries and all the
primary languages so if I install the
Python Google cloud library into my into
pit so pip install Google - cloud I can
then import spanner from Google cloud I
instantiate a client so that client
allows me to talk to the service I then
say I mean my instance so please give me
my instance ID and then from the
instance I can grab my database so I say
what is my database ID and then I ask my
instance for the database I now have a
handle to my database where I can start
to send queries so I could do results
sets by saying databases that execute
sequel and passage sequel queries and so
these ten lines of code are all that is
necessary to be able to be up and
running with your cloud spanner instance
we really try to make it as easy as
possible there's lots of intermediate
steps that are happening here that we've
been able to obscure by having really
strong client libraries that do a lot of
the heavy lifting underneath the hood
for you things like connection pooling
and things that could be gotchas if you
aren't familiar with how to use the
service so before right before we get
into the demo how does this fit into the
broader schema so cloud spanner sounds
fantastic is it the solution for
everything the answer is no cloud
spanner is one of a portfolio of
solutions that allow you to build your
applications on top of Google cloud
platform so starting with cloud sequel
so if you have a framework whether it be
Django or WordPress or Drupal that
requires my sequel then you can use
cloud sequel to manage that might people
instance for you so it's a traditional
are to be a mask that's being managed
for you by Google if you have a
document database workload commonly in
mobile and web then cloud datastore
provides you that document database
fully scalable it's shared resources you
can literally start from zero dollars a
month all the way up to snap scale we
just went public so you can scale all
the way up on cloud datastore if your
data is non relational and fits into a
document database workload cloud
BigTable is our analytics database so
this allows you to do low latency single
millisecond reads and writes and really
fast table scans for your IOT time
series ad Tech Data Mark Tech Data it's
a fantastic solution for that and then
bigquery is our data warehouse that
allows you to write all your data in
mostly append some mutations so you can
update and clean up your data but it's
really our data warehouse so what cloud
spanner does in the portfolio is gives
you a place that if you've gone to my
sequel and cause sequel and you're using
that as your solution if you need to be
able to scale past it you know that
Google provides you an option so it
really gives you a future proof path to
be able to move from your existing
application on either my speak role or
Postgres or we're gonna happen to be
using and continue to grow out as a
scale out relational database and with
that I'm going to bring up Robert
to get started on the demo one of the
things one of the questions that I just
went through I've used a lot of words
flowcharts are usually helpful so what
we did here is we put together a
decision tree that allows you to decide
which database service you would use for
which which offering so first of all is
your data structured or unstructured if
your data is unstructured you're going
to put it in a Google Cloud storage that
way you can use it and access it there
if you need mobile SDKs that firebase
storage will provide you a mobile SDK on
the Google Cloud storage if your data is
structured then the question is is your
data analytics is you have an analytics
workload in which case you'll come over
into the analytics branch if you need
low latency and lots of mutations use
cloud BigTable if you don't use cloud
bigquery coming back down the middle if
your data is relational and the answer
is no then you have cloud datastore and
if you have mobile applications
you have firebase real-time database
that provides you mobile SDKs for iOS
Java and the mobile applications if your
data is relational and the question is
you need horizontal scalability if you
don't need horizontal scalability than
cloud sequel is a great solution for you
and it's going to be your easiest path
to building an application if you do
need the horizontal scalability cloud
spanner is there to meet your needs so
this is a quick way for you to kind of
navigate which of the various database
technologies will serve the need for
your application and lastly before we
get to the demo as I said before partner
integration is very important to us it's
why we spend a lot of time on the JDBC
driver so we're very excited to have X
plenty zoom data looker and
MicroStrategy and eye charts they all
are in the process of launching our
already launched support for cloud
spanner so some of your favorite bi
tools are already integrated and we're
working with informatica Illuma and
tableau
they've started work and they'll be
rolling out their solutions later in the
year so again if you are already using
tableau or looker one of these solutions
in your stack we're going to make sure
that we're integrated from the very
beginning to make it as easy as possible
to migrate data in and out of cloud
spanner so with that I give it to Robert
all right Thank You Derek hello everyone
so Dominic present you a lot of features
and arguments why to use spanner so I
want to show you how you can get started
today with it so the first stop should
be cloud to Google comes like spanner
where you find the wealth of information
about the our spanner product you find
white papers best practices you find
Eric Brewers recap on the cap theorem
and spanner so there you also find your
developer Docs and I want to stop here
and ask a question how many of you are
developers in the room awesome so use
the right audience for me so we as
Dominic mentions we have a couple of
client libraries so Java OGS and Shou
and Python I can't concentrate and go if
I get it today so to get started as an
instance you go to the Google Cloud
console so to unfold the cloud at Google
come make sure that you logged in and
then we have on the left side and I
straw here where you can type in spinner
and you find it and you can go there so
to create an instance you click on
incidence you choose the name so the
awesome spinner for instance and then I
select regional configuration now we
have the as Dominic mentions the
multi-regional is coming up later this
year right now you can choose between
three regions a jyarei and US I going to
choose Europe I'm personally from Europe
so I prefer Europe I want to have my
spanner instance to give me all the
answers so I select 42 notes and we
create and as you can see with the snap
of the finger you have your instance
with 42 notes so now we can get started
and create a database so here I choose
and say ok I created demo database and I
create an a schema so I like to select
the table you can all do this also from
from the command line with G Cloud SDK
so download to GTA 3 cloud SDK and then
you can do all this on the command line
as well so for instance we have the
singer we had an ID and in perfect and
then we say a name which is a string
here okay stop and then you select your
primary key you at the table and now you
have your first table now we can add
another table and this as we mentioned
before I think we had albums here we can
now interleave this as well so I wonder
for instance in the leave or not so it
can go through all this and create this
let's choose this I want to leave the
tables with my single table I want to
delete on cascade delete so I get
already the ID as my primary key from
the album and then for instance I say
it's like an album name here alright and
again a string we're done you have to
choose and primary key as well and I'm
yet to table here say opening ok cool
and we create
so that's basically done and background
as we mentioned before we have online
updates so you can see already it's done
cool now I want to switch to a different
instance where I have some pre-loaded
data so in this pre-loaded data I have a
scenario where I have like think of
Ticketmaster or something where you can
buy tickets and to explain that to you a
little bit I have a crappy schema here
sorry about my my drawing skills so what
I going to show you here I want to show
you some best practices how we came up
with the scheme and what you have to pay
attention to if you want to scale
horizontally with your database so here
we have a multi event think of a tour
for instance a cold plate or which is in
many many countries so the cold plate or
would be a multi event each of the
concerts in each country is an event
then we have different venues which have
different seating configurations think
of like a stadium which can have sports
events or concert and then we have a
ticket category which basically gives us
attaches a price to a ticket for certain
event so with the cold call a concert in
a stadium we have a certain ticket price
for each seat and then you see on the
right upper corner and a counter that
would basically somebody who come to our
website and signs up and wants to buy a
ticket that would be representing that
account so now this table preloaded here
and what you can also see here in the
console is you have a multitude of
things that you can check into so we see
already here my database is mere seven
gigabytes big I can go to the monitor
tab where I see things like how many
notes do I have how much the CPU
utilization have do I have and we
recommend not to go over 75% so if you
see that you're approaching the suit
realization you can easily add notes you
see operations and throughputs and
things like that so this little spikes
that you see here was me loading the
database okay so I want to show you an
example query that I have here
[Music]
which is based on the schema that I
showed just showed you so what the
capability that you have as well here in
the console you can directly run your
crease out of the console so I gonna run
this tree it should be rather quick
what does is create do it basically
gives you back the the events for the
next week where we still have a lot of
seats available for this event so you
see here we have a couple of events with
10,000 available seats and then these
availability basically how many tickets
didn't V V not we have not sold so far
so this is four into the query that you
could use promote events that are not
going well in terms of selling your
tickets now we see if I go to the
explanation tab you get a query
explained and you can see like what is
what is this query doing like I see here
a couple of table scans that I'm doing
distributed unions and things like that
and I looked at this query before and I
saw like okay this is not a performance
optimal so what can I do if a query is
not performing optimal and as like with
any like bigger database relational
database that you have out there you
have the possibility to give the
optimizer some hints and that's exactly
what are going to do here so it was
mentioned by Dominic that we have the
ANSI 2011 SQL standard with extensions
and one of these extensions is that I
can force an index for instance so I
have an in an index defined on my
ceiling category and I say add and then
the places and say force in the
exceeding category by ID and then I run
this whole query again and if you have
paid attention you saw this like really
ran before and 750 milliseconds so
fingers crossed this is better now you
see here I did an op them and optimized
a hint and now my career runs three
times faster and scans a lot less rows
alright so another thing what we have
are all of the cloud products they are
integrated with this is products that we
have so one of the products for instance
for monitoring is our stack driver
solution so inspect drive what you can
do is you can monitor your clout
spanner instance and I've here
pre-created dashboards and I want to add
some more time some more things so right
now I have nodes and storage which I'm
monitoring if you want to add more
things you basically can select from the
a chart you can have here resource type
cloudspinner and then you can select the
metric that you want to want to select
so for instance I want to check this you
the CPU utilization so see you - ok and
then you can select and say ok I only
want to have that monitoring one of my
databases the nice thing of this is you
can also set up alerts with this so if
your - the spanner instance is
approaching like a certain creative
utilization or or storage then you can
get alerts through your phone and can
easily increase the note count so a note
count adding or taking notes away if you
want to save money or you like
utilization is slow you can all the time
go to your instance edit notes and for
instance go from 8 to 5 and that's safe
and then we will reduce the notes so
it's a fully managed solution where it's
very easy to to set it up get started
load data scale scale in and scale out
as you wish so how are we doing in time
ok so one more thing Dominic sent
mentioned he is a Python guy I'm a go
guy so I'm usually doing go so how does
it look and go it's very easy as well so
what you do is basically you have the
database path where you load or we take
the the instance or the project the
instance and this is the database that
you want to talk to you set up in a
client we have that here and then you
can basically run your create so what
I'm doing here is a very simple query I
want to have all the multi events that
are happening for today and because I
don't care if like I'm a little bit like
out of date with this I actually can
define time bound for this query so I
can actually say to spinner and say like
hey I don't want to have a strong
consistent read in this case
because I don't think that we update the
multi-event so so often so I'm okay if I
do I have a little bit of snail Ness and
this is the case what you see here I'm
saying like I'm okay with 15 seconds of
stillness and that allows you for
instance is a multi regional set up to
read from a local copy in a different
region even so if there is not the
primary copy of it all right so with
that I want to lead into a Q&A and 1r6
dominique to come back on stage and we
are here for you to answer any question
and so we're gonna do we've got about 15
minutes for Q&A so if you have questions
please come up to the mic last thing I
want to put a quick plug in for some of
our other sessions so if you're
interested in spanner and databases in
general we have the spanner 201 session
tomorrow we have a great session and
optimizing cloud sequel performance a
good class again and talking about other
storage solutions so I didn't spend time
on Google Cloud storage or some of the
other ones and also zero to apps live
coding and apps with firebase in GCP
which is one of my favorite sessions
that I've seen
[Music]
you